Mr Beast is tapping into the NBA he is
one of the biggest YouTube Sensations
with a net worth of 500 million dollars
and he's from North Carolina so the
Charlotte Hornets Chief Revenue officer
thought there was no better guy to help
them flip the script and turn heads Mr
beats and the Hornets entered a
partnership agreement for his feastfuls
brand to appear as the team's one and
only Jersey patch Mr Beast will now be
the first creator-led bran to do a deal
like this his sights were set on the NBA
because it's most digitally native and
the Hornets love the idea because as a
team outside of the top 10 in
merchandise sales they think Mr BEAST's
popularity will help Drive additional
jersey sales